bonjour pierre emmanuel comme anne
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin dans la matinale
verte et france premier grand oral donc
pour emmanuel macron en tant que
président du conseil européen à quoi ça
sert ce grand oral concrètement
alors ce grand oral va définir les
priorités de la présidence française
pendant six mois mais on les connaît
déjà parce qu elles ont déjà été
exprimée par emmanuel macron en décembre
et je dirais c'est en quelque sorte la
feuille de route pour l'union européenne
les prochains mois et ce qui est
intéressant ce seront les discussions
parlement européen avec les différents
chefs des partis politiques qui vont
prendre position et qui vont révéler un
petit peu les les fractures les fissures
les débats au sein de cette union
européenne qui
depuis pas mal de temps est en crise et
il sera extrêmement difficile pour la
présidence française évidemment de
montrer un front uni et de décider quels
seront les les les priorités
géopolitiques en particulier de l'union
européenne dans un monde fracture est
fissurée définir les priorités de
l'union européenne mais concrètement est
ce qu'il aura les moyens d'agir
la grande difficulté c'est évidemment la
fracturation la fragmentation
géopolitique de l'europe à l'image du
monde après la guerre froide le monde
bipolaire nous nous allons vers un monde
de plus en plus multi centres et
multipolaire avec une rivalité des
grandes puissances et l'union européenne
a du mal à se positionner dans cet
environnement parce que les états
membres eux mêmes ont des intérêts
différents une perception de leur
sécurité en fonction de leur position
géographique et leur héritage historique
qui ceux qui sont différents et et ce
grand oral intervient dans un contexte
extrêmement particulier puisqu'il y à la
campagne présidentielle en france
d'ailleurs dans l'hémicycle il ya un
eurodéputé qui s'appelle yannick jadot
et qui est également candidat
il n'y a pas un mélange des genres là
qui va se produire
je crois que c'est c'est intéressant
d'avoir un débat au parlement européen y
compris un débat qui a des connotations
nationale parce que s'il n'y a pas de
participation des débats
au parlement européen en fonction des
différents partis des différentes
visions dans chaque nation européenne il
n'y aura pas de débat européen crédible
donc c'est intéressant peut-être la
difficulté effectivement c'est que dès
la présidence française aura du mal à
mettre en avant un projet très ambitieux
à cause des
fissures et des désaccords au niveau
national en france qui sont très forts
parce qu'on sait bien que
le prix dans macron met en avant une
europe très progressiste
avec une un projet assez ambitieux de
d'intégration européenne tandis que la
plupart des partis d'opposition en
france sont plutôt pour une europe des
nations avec moins d'intégration est
basée sur le principe d' équilibre cher
aux halles à l'héritage du général de
gaulle est ce qu'elle sera question
également d'immigration à votre
connaissance je vous pose la question
parce qu'un candidat à la présidentielle
eric zemmour en l'occurrence sera lui à
calais pour livrer sa vision l'europe
donc on voit il ya déjà une bataille à
ce niveau là oui d'ailleurs c'est une
est une des priorités en fait de la
présidence française y en a 3 c'est la
question des frontières donc lié à
l'immigration la défense et la sécurité
et l'économie et donc cette question de
l'awb de schengen comment mieux
contrôler les frontières c'est un sujet
controversé parce que derrière il y à
des finalités européenne différente non
seulement au niveau de l'union les états
membres ne sont pas d'accord entre eux
il ya les états les gouvernements je
dirais comme emmanuel macron l'allemagne
qui sont qui défendent en réalité non
pas une europe civilisationnel mais une
europe libérale avec des frontières
maîtrisé mais quand même ouvertes à
l'immigration parce que dans le modèle
libéral les sociétés considèrent qu'ils
ont besoin d'une migration assez forte
en raison du déficit démographique
européens tandis que d'autres nations
européennes en particulier la hongrie la
pologne les pays d'europe centrale en
général sont plutôt favorable à une
europe des nations basé sur une
civilisation européenne avec maîtrise
des frontières beaucoup plus forte et de
limiter dans le plus possible
l'immigration extra européenne pour
éviter une dissolution des nations et
une
fissuration de la civilisation
européenne une prise de parole qui
intervient également dans un contexte de
changements au niveau de l'europe il n'y
a plus en gueule à merkel est-ce que
emmanuel macron va pouvoir
renouer en tout cas continuer c'est
cette alliance franco-allemande où se
tourne-t-il vers d'autres partenaires
comme l'italien par exemple
alors dans le projet européen dans son
histoire il n'ya pas il y aura il n'y a
pas d'accord
au niveau l'union européenne sans accord
franco-allemand préalable même si c'est
de plus en plus difficile parce que
l'union européenne elle mène est de plus
en plus fragmenté et donc c'est toujours
une
partenariat centrale pour les définir
les priorités et la vision de l'union
européenne mais le problème principal
c'est précisément cette rivalité franco
allemande qui perdure depuis les
origines de la construction européenne
et qui a été renforcé par
l'unification allemande où il ya une
asymétrie entre l'allemagne qui est la
puissance centrale en europe dont
l'économie est florissante étant la
france sont plus marginalisés après
l'élargissement de l'union européenne en
europe centrale et orientale et la
france n'est plus le centre de la
construction européenne et c'est
pourquoi
emmanuel macron après le départ dans
gala merkel va essayer de repositionner
la france au centre du projet mais ce
sera extrêmement difficile parce que les
finalités européenne entre l'allemagne
et la france sont différentes la france
est plus favorable à une europe
souveraine une europe puissance
tandis que l'allemagne ne compte des
repas le projet européen autrement qu'un
sous-ensemble de l'espace euro
atlantique
avec une
partenariat privilégié avec les états
unis et l'otan
merci beaucoup pierre emmanuel
commeinhes de toutes vos explications ce
matin en direct dans la matinale verte
et france